est-ce que tu étais déjà venu à l'abbaye
de noirlac du tout à vrai dire je
connaissais pas le lieu donc c'est mon
première fois j'adore toi tu as grandi
pas très loin du côté de blois
exactement au montils saouti village à
côté
il paraît que tu as joué au basket au
sila bah ouais ouais ouais quand qu'elle
vend donc tu étais est un peu la
patronne des parcs et des paniers des
trois points c'était toi
ouais je me plais pas mal de 3 points
mais ouais non j'ai fait beaucoup
d'années à blois et a joint un grand
niveau
ouais j'ai fait les championnats rennes
joue j'ai fini
ils sélection de la région centre tout
cela c'est à ce moment là qu'on prend
jours de pause
la championne la musique c'est une vraie
passion depuis tout petit ouais c'est
une passion que je suis petit après j'ai
commencé par le hautbois j'étais au
collège j'étais moi ouais j'ai vite
lâché c'est très galère et après je me
suis mise m je me suis mise à la guitare
il ya six sept ans je dirais sur
internet tu vois j'allais voir des
petites vidéos sur youtube puis
j'apprenais comme ça et après il ya un
spot aussi diablo qui s'appelle la
fabrique c'est un espace jeunes est en
fait il propose des salles de musique
des salles de danse un truc comme ça et
donc je me retrouvais avec plein de
musiciens et c'est là où tout c'est une
journée en fonte et tout s'est enchaîné
j'ai commencé à écrire une chanson mais
pourquoi est ce que les parents ont
toujours été derrière toi ouais ils ont
toujours été des codes jeu façon que ce
soit de la musique ou le sport
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des banques
qui me soutiennent vraiment beaucoup
donc ils sont toujours présents on m'a
dit que ce serait ton père qui t'aurait
inscrit à the voice aux émissions le
télé crochet par laquelle la france
entière tu as découvert mais c'est vrai
ça ouais c'est lui qui a envoyé la vidéo
c'est moi qui l'ait bassiner bon 2,3 en
2011 j'aimerais bien faire c'est vrai
c'est tout
mais j'avais pas eu le cran d'envoyer
mes vidéos et elle qu'est ce qui te
disait ton père ce moment là mon père il
ya une file est tout le temps en train
de me dire profiter jeunes mais cette
envie de faire un truc fait le moi je te
soutiens je suis derrière tu vois donc
lui il avait cette approche là ma mère
elle était plus en mode fait les études
et où la fac avant donc j'avais les deux
tu vois c'est un équilibre assez
intéressant et en fait ils envoient les
vidéos et puis ça s'est fait assez vite
il a fallu que tu fasses un choix aussi
entre la musique et puis tu nous parler
de tes études eh ouais après j'ai quand
même eu passer ma naissance c'était
quand même espagnol ouais littérature
espagnole à tour car il n'était pas
obligé la facilité et en fait ouais non
j'ai appris je voulais faire mon master
et puis j'ai une proposition concrète
maisons de disques et je me suis dit
et maintenant c'est maintenant qu'on
lâche tôt et on y va et je regarde pas
si on devait parler de ta musique
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire parce que
toi je sais que tu aimes pas être mis
dans des cases
ouais c'est ça exactement ma si on peut
parler de ma musique je pense qu'on
pourrait dire qu elle est colorée
parce que justement il ya plein de
couleurs ya plein de styles musicaux
comme tu dis j'ai pas envie de rentrer
dans des cases donc je m'enferme
vraiment pas si j'ai envie de faire du
reggae ska et du reggae si j'ai envie de
faire de la pop du rap je le fais je
mélange un peu tous les styles et ses
logements bah c'est surtout ça j'ai
plutôt l'impression qu'on est dans un
grand métissage way de musique c'est
exactement ça avoir une belle sono
mondiale
et là on s'en rend compte vraiment avec
chico tu peux nous parler de ce titre
ben ce titre justement c'est un mélange
un peu de reggae pop un peu urbania est
en fait chez baiia du français de
l'espagnol et sa part d'un mec qui nous
représente un peu tous tous ceux qui ont
envie de casser la routine travail tu
vas mal au dos d'autres ça s'est un peu
machin par moments donc c'est un peu le
mec qui va tout lâcher voyage et
s'écouter y arriver et puis voilà opare
ouais c'est l'idée aussi qu'on peut
aller vraiment toucher du bout des
doigts
nos rêves ouais c'est exactement ça on
des fruits sont ils sont assez proches
de nous les rênes donc un pourquoi
pourquoi pas tout lâcher pour faire ce
qu'on a vraiment envie de faire en fond
est-ce que ce titre c'est aussi la porte
d'entrée pour un album ouais ouais on va
pas se mentir ça fait deux ans que je
vois sur sur plein de titres et j'ai dû
écrire 40 chansons j'ai collaboré avec
pas mal de monde là je commence à me
retrouver et ouais c'est un morceau qui
fera partie de l'album et je pense qu'un
album bientôt criminelle non mais voilà
ça va venir ça l'album sur le fait
l'arrêt et puis ce soir camille tu nous
fais un autre cadeau tu va nous proposer
une version très différente de la radio
edit de chico ici à l'abbaye de noirlac
avec une particularité quand même c'est
l'acoustique et un temps de
réverbération de 4 5 7 secondes
ouais ouais c'est une superbe expérience
j'ai jamais fait ça je m'attendais à ce
qu'il y ait un micro un truc tu vois et
en fait c'est pas intéressant je trouve
en mai sauf l'activité s'arrête robin
non mais c'est vrai le lieu est vraiment
magnifique et puis la fin ça une semaine
en été quand même assez incroyable à
quel point cela change la chanson bah en
fait j'allais la faire beaucoup plus
rapidement et là je me dis que le plus
posé c'est beaucoup plus joli et puis
c'est pas ça fait une belle reverb ya
pas besoin d'en d'électronique coin
quand on sent qu il soit personnes qui
téléphonent qui se passe